elektra und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen videospiel wir gerade mal auf
momente games eine runde 24 rsg aber es
ist kein tag wie der andere denn mir
wurde gesagt dass ich auf meinem ts
sichern araber eingefunden hat und den
haben wir hier gab einen channel mit zu
interviewen
unser gespräch auf jeden fall
okay okay
you know how german server
ob seines lebens
what time is it
die urteile sind in saudi arabien auf er
reagiert nicht alter ist müsst ihr vor
und sagen du kannst du kannst ja mal die
original zeit raus oder können wir
checken ob er auch ins tor
das müsste vor uns in saudi arabia
geschrieben was hat er geschrieben nicht
mal vor da bist du hatte ich immer den
hat er was herz geschrieben sprich mit
mir im chat zu schätzen übersetzen also
hat wahrscheinlich google translator
gemacht habe ich mit mir im chat zurück
zu schätzen
chad kugler sensations brl besetzt
locker seine sprache kommt in
deutschland lockte der benutzten schutz
okay wir fragen wie viel uhr ist es in
saudi arabien news google translate sie
so erkennt nicht unser zeit vom hat oder
was hat mir die anderen
ich glaube nicht
egal der cola fanta weil die reaktion
vor dem so guck mal wie spät es da jetzt
könnte sie ja eine stunde nach und
einzelnen also mit der substanz weiter
kochen aber auf arabisch
dadurch können google schon station
benutzen kann die kann ich irgendwie den
jetta einbinden
wahrscheinlich versuchen wir zu
übersetzen arabisch erkennst du siehst
du siehst so musste sowie für us
personen
so soll es sein das war das dein name
nur dass sein name in new york an sind
und wieso wie sowas sagt er nur gesagt
auch nicht nur benjamin nein ich hab ich
heiße nicht zeitig und görlitzer und
german service ranking rang in new york
5000 ist das gut 5000 nicht zusammen
geschrieben 11 505.000 jetzt nicht
verpflichtet alles schön spiel full
screen welches lesen sie mussten ja okay
das recht dass wir gute voraussetzungen
für mich zu überleben
ich suchte ich gerade packt dann auch
meine rap skillz support wenig hinter
uns haben leute wenn die laufwerke drauf
halter wieso ist es nicht hier oben ein
einziger scheiße mann ist websites
twitter liegen lassen ich hab ein herz
der klassische fns finde ich hier finde
ich cool sie so ich festgestellt dass es
sich tatsächlich schnell den kopf dass
es sich das ja okay wir machen das
gehört zum 2 1
richtig zur sache
die haben uns geholt okay er hätte das
easy gerissen ist sie so einem bett in
zweifel games are you good in zweifel
games have sex with your life you know
how to hack know how to can you can't
teach me hintergrund kleine schwester
okay so
die hälfte dieser termin ist der jurist
ist dran am ende ist ein kind heute
leider ziehen der vater mit 14 sie so
das ist niemals ein treue halten
okay so der ein häckchen darum welche
moneyball release represent bekommen
jetzt ändern denn dann wissen was ein
abschlepper angeht ist doch weltberühmt
aber abschlepper bushido bushido oder
sido auf minecraft minecraft ok alles
klar leute dann im nächsten video wie
ich mit so minecraft spieler das war es
mir heute ganz ehrlich was für ein
zufall war dass ich mit ben aufnehmen
wir schreiben diesmal also ein araber
ist hier und das war ein echter aber
weil er oder was meint ihr wahlrecht
weil er nicht recht glauben ist recht
eure meinung in die kommentare
wenn du dass deine meinung in die
kommentare schreiben
check point update verlinkt und bis
morgen dann mit sie so rossi